bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice", numele meu este John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM
Quantum aceasta este lecția numărul 15 din serie și este a treia lecție din al patrulea modul, care este despre erori cuantice
corecție până acum am văzut câteva exemple de coduri cuantice corectoare de erori, inclusiv codul Shore pe nouă qubiți
codul Steane pe 7 qubiți și codul pe 5 qubiți și am discutat și despre formalismul stabilizator, care oferă
o bază matematică din care putem descrie și analiza acestea și multe alte coduri cuantice corectoare de erori
codurile pe care tocmai le-am menționat sunt fără îndoială interesante și reprezintă un punct de plecare natural pentru o
explorare a corecției cuantice a erorilor problema este că ele pot tolera doar o rată de eroare foarte mică
corectarea unei erori pe un qubit din cinci, șapte sau nouă nu e rea, dar cel mai probabil, cel puțin pe cât bănuim
va trebui să fim capabili să tolerăm mult mai multe erori decât atât pentru a face computația cuantică la scară largă o
realitate în această lecție vom arunca o primă privire asupra unor construcții mai sofisticate de coduri cuantice corectoare de erori, inclusiv coduri care pot
tolera o rată de eroare mult mai mare decât cele pe care le-am văzut până acum și sunt considerate candidați promițători pentru corecția cuantică practică a erorilor în
dispozitive fizice reale iată o scurtă prezentare a lecției: vom începe cu o clasă de
coduri cuantice corectoare de erori cunoscute sub numele de coduri CSS, denumite după cercetătorii care le-au descoperit primii: Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor și Andrew Steane construcția codului CSS permite luarea anumitor perechi de coduri clasice
corectoare de erori și combinarea lor într-un cod cuantic corector de erori ca parte a acestei discuții vom
arrunca o privire destul de rapidă asupra codurilor liniare clasice și vom discuta și despre câteva proprietăți de bază ale codurilor CSS
a doua parte a lecției este despre un cod cunoscut sub numele de codul Toric, care este un exemplu fundamental și cu adevărat
frumos de cod cuantic corector de erori care poate tolera o rată de eroare relativ ridicată de fapt
codul Toric nu este un singur exemplu de cod cuantic corector de erori, ci mai degrabă o familie infinită de coduri, câte unul pentru
fiecare număr întreg pozitiv începând de la doi și în ultima parte a lecției vom discuta pe scurt despre câteva alte
familii de coduri cuantice, inclusiv coduri de suprafață care sunt strâns legate de codul toric, precum și
coduri de culoare oamenii studiază coduri clasice corectoare de erori din anii 1940
și este un subiect fascinant și bogat codurile liniare sunt poate cel mai simplu tip de eroare clasică
cod corector și voi explica exact ce înseamnă cuvântul liniar în acest context imediat, dar un mod simplu
de a exprima ce sunt este că sunt coduri stabilizatoare care se întâmplă să fie clasice și vom vedea în scurt timp că
codurile CSS sunt practic perechi de coduri liniare clasice combinate împreună pentru a crea o eroare cuantică
cod corector deci pentru a putea purta această discuție va trebui să înțelegem câteva lucruri de bază despre
codurile liniare clasice mai întâi vom lua Sigma ca alfabet binar pentru toată această
discuție și acum când ne referim la un cod liniar clasic înțelegem o mulțime C de șiruri binare de lungime n pentru un
număr întreg pozitiv n satisfăcând o singură proprietate de bază, și anume că dacă u și v sunt șiruri binare în C, atunci șirul
u XOR v este de asemenea în C prin u XOR v înțelegem, apropo, SAU exclusiv pe biți al lui u și v, exact
cum am văzut de mai multe ori în lecțiile cinci și șase din secțiunea de algoritmi cuantici a seriei și aceasta este semnificația
unui cod clasic liniar în esență ne gândim la șirurile binare de lungime n ca vectori n-dimensionali
ale căror intrări sunt toate fie zero fie unu, dar în loc de adunarea obișnuită a vectorilor peste reale sau complexe
folosim adunarea modulo 2, care este pur și simplu XOR-ul, deci dacă avem
două cuvinte de cod u și v, adică u și v sunt șiruri binare în C, atunci u plus v modulo 2 sau cu alte cuvinte u XOR
v trebuie să fie de asemenea un cuvânt de cod în C și apropo, această implicație trebuie să fie adevărată chiar dacă u este egal cu v, nimic nu exclude
această posibilitate și asta implică că orice cod liniar clasic trebuie să conțină șirul de zerouri, deoarece
XOR-ul pe biți al oricărui șir cu el însuși este șirul de zerouri de exemplu codul de
repetiție pe trei biți este un cod liniar clasic: în particular există două alegeri posibile pentru u și două alegeri posibile
pentru v și este destul de trivial să parcurgi perechile posibile pentru a vedea că obținem întotdeauna un cuvânt de cod când luăm XOR-ul pe biți
iată un alt exemplu, numit codul Hamming [7,4,3] acesta este unul dintre primele coduri clasice de erori
corectoare descoperit vreodată și constă din 16 șiruri binare de lungime șapte există o logică foarte simplă
în spatele selecției acestor șiruri, dar nu voi explica asta în acest video și ar trebui să menționez că uneori vei vedea aceste șiruri inversate, dar
deocamdată punctul principal este că dacă luăm oricare două dintre aceste șiruri și le aplicăm XOR obținem alt șir din
cod deci este un cod liniar și notația [7,4,3] în paranteze pătrate simple înseamnă ceva analog cu parantezele duble
pe care le-am menționat în lecția anterioară pentru codurile stabilizatoare, dar aici este pentru codurile liniare clasice
în particular cuvintele de cod au șapte biți, sunt 16 cuvinte de cod, deci putem codifica patru biți folosind codul și
se întâmplă să fie un cod de distanță trei, adică trebuie să inversezi cel puțin trei biți ai oricărui cuvânt de cod pentru a obține un
cuvânt de cod diferit și asta implică că poate corecta până la o eroare de inversare de bit acestea sunt exemple simple de
coduri, dar chiar și exemplul codului Hamming [7,4,3] pare cam misterios când listăm pur și simplu toate cuvintele de cod, deci avem nevoie de modalități mai bune de
a descrie codurile liniare clasice și există două modalități naturale de a face asta una este să descriem codurile liniare clasice
dând un set minimal de cuvinte de cod care generează codul, adică luând toate submulțimile posibile
ale acestor cuvinte de cod și aplicând XOR obținem codul întreg și aceasta este exprimată în termeni matematici
pe ecran o altă modalitate de a gândi la asta este că privim acest cod ca un subspațiu al unui spațiu vectorial și această
mulțime de generatoare este o bază pentru acel subspațiu ținând minte că acesta este un spațiu vectorial în care aritmetica se face modulo 2, dacă avem m generatoare vom
ajunge la un cod cu două la puterea m elemente, fiecare generator dublează numărul de elemente din cod și
este consistent cu faptul că codurile liniare clasice peste alfabetul binar includ întotdeauna un număr de șiruri care este o putere a lui
doi a doua modalitate naturală de a descrie un cod liniar clasic este prin verificări de paritate, mai exact aceasta este o listă minimală
de șiruri binare cu aceeași lungime ca șirurile din cod, astfel încât șirurile din cod sunt exact cele al căror produs scalar binar
cu fiecare dintre aceste șiruri de verificare a parității este zero, unde produsul scalar binar este pur și simplu produsul interior obișnuit
WEBVTT
modulo 2 și din nou acesta este ceva cu care ne-am întâlnit în lecția cinci în contextul algoritmilor de
interogare și motivul pentru care se numesc șiruri de verificare a parității este că un șir dat u are produsul binar egal cu
zero cu v dacă și numai dacă biții lui u corespunzători celor de unu din v au paritate
pară când descriem un cod liniar clasic în acest mod printr-o listă minimală de șiruri de verificare a parității, fiecare verificare
de paritate împarte la jumătate numărul de șiruri din cod, deci pentru un singur cod descris în aceste două moduri diferite vom avea întotdeauna m + r egal cu
n un lucru important de observat aici este că produsul scalar binar nu este un produs interior în sens formal și în
particular când două șiruri au produsul scalar binar egal cu zero nu înseamnă că sunt ortogonale în modul obișnuit în care ne gândim la
ortogonalitate de exemplu produsul scalar binar al șirului unu unu cu el însuși este zero, deci este posibil ca
unul dintre aceste șiruri de verificare a parității să fie el însuși în cod, deci acesta este ceva de reținut
de exemplu, după cum știm deja, codul de repetiție pe 3 biți este un cod liniar, deci poate fi descris în ambele aceste
moduri în particular există o singură alegere pentru un generator care funcționează și aceea este 111 și putem descrie alternativ
codul cu aceste două șiruri de verificare a parității care ar trebui să pară familiare din discuțiile noastre anterioare despre acest
cod iar pentru codul Hamming [7,4,3] putem folosi acești generatori și aceste verificări de
paritate și apropo, toate șirurile noastre de verificare a parității se dovedesc a fi ele însele în cod
un ultim comentariu despre codurile liniare clasice doar pentru a le conecta cu formalismul stabilizator: aceste șiruri de verificare a parității
sunt echivalente cu generatoarele stabilizatoare unde avem doar matrici Pauli Z și identitate, de exemplu șirurile de verificare a parității
110 și 011 pentru codul de repetiție pe 3 biți corespund precis generatoarelor stabilizatoare ZZ identitate
și identitate ZZ și aceasta este consistent cu discuția noastră despre observabilele de acest tip din lecția anterioară
în continuare vom discuta despre codurile CSS, care sunt coduri stabilizatoare ce pot fi obținute combinând anumite
perechi de coduri liniare clasice cu același număr de biți în codificările lor aceasta nu funcționează pentru oricare două
coduri liniare clasice: cele două coduri trebuie să aibă o anumită relație, după cum vom vedea în curând, dar cu toate acestea această
construcție deschide o mulțime de posibilități pentru coduri cuantice corectoare de erori bazate în parte pe ceea ce am învățat din peste 75 de ani de
teorie clasică a codificării am menționat deja că în formalismul stabilizator generatoarele
stabilizatoare care conțin doar matrici Pauli Z și identitate sunt echivalente cu verificările de paritate, de exemplu în codul de repetiție pe trei biți
putem folosi șirurile de verificare a parității 1 1 0 și 011 care impun ca primii doi biți din stânga să fie
egali și ultimii doi biți din dreapta să fie egali pentru fiecare șir din cod și aceste două șiruri de verificare a parității corespund precis generatoarelor
stabilizatoare ZZ identitate și identitate ZZ pentru codul Hamming [7,4,3] putem folosi
aceste șiruri de verificare a parității și ele corespund acestor generatoare stabilizatoare unde pur și simplu înlocuim fiecare unu cu un Z și fiecare zero cu identitatea
s-ar putea să recunoști aceste generatoare stabilizatoare deoarece acestea sunt trei dintre cele șase generatoare stabilizatoare pentru codul Steane pe 7 qubiți, ceea ce
cu siguranță nu este o coincidență și vom vedea exact ce se întâmplă aici în curând vom da numele Z
generatoare stabilizatoare generatoarelor stabilizatoare de acest tip, adică care au doar factori tensori Pauli Z și identitate
deci X și Y nu apar niciodată într-un generator stabilizator Z putem considera de asemenea
generatoare stabilizatoare în care apar doar matrici Pauli X și identitate și ne putem gândi la generatoarele stabilizatoare de acest tip ca fiind complet analoge
cu generatoarele stabilizatoare Z cu excepția că ele descriu practic verificări de paritate în baza plus minus mai degrabă decât în baza
standard de exemplu revenind la codul Hamming [7,4,3] ne putem gândi la
celelalte trei generatoare stabilizatoare din codul Steane pe 7 qubiți care urmează exact același pattern ca pentru generatoarele stabilizatoare Z pentru acest
cod, dar de data aceasta înlocuim X pentru unu în loc de Z și ce obținem din doar aceste trei generatoare stabilizatoare
este un cod care include cele 16 stări afișate aici, pe care le obținem aplicând porți Hadamard stărilor bazei standard
care corespund șirurilor din codul Hamming [7,4,3] și desigur spațiul nostru de cod include și
combinații liniare ale acestor stări în mod firesc, generatoarele stabilizatoare de această formă se numesc generatoare stabilizatoare X
deci nu sunt permise y-uri sau z-uri de data aceasta și acum putem defini codurile CSS în
termeni simpli codurile CSS sunt coduri stabilizatoare ce pot fi exprimate folosind doar generatoare stabilizatoare Z
și generatoare stabilizatoare X deci nu sunt permise y-uri și nu sunt permise x-uri și z-uri în același generator stabilizator
și pentru a fi siguri că e clar, trebuie să avem în vedere că există libertate în modul în care alegem generatoarele stabilizatoare pentru codurile stabilizatoare
și ceea ce spune această definiție este că un cod CSS este unul pentru care este posibil să se aleagă doar generatoare stabilizatoare Z și X
dar în general ai putea alege generatoare stabilizatoare diferite care s-ar putea să nu fie generatoare stabilizatoare Z sau X dacă ai vrea
iată doar cel mai simplu exemplu non-trivial de cod CSS care poate exista, unde există atât un generator stabilizator Z
cât și un generator stabilizator X și verificarea asta nu necesită mai mult decât o privire rapidă, dat fiind că știm deja din
lecția anterioară că acesta este un cod stabilizator valid spațiul de cod este unidimensional, este spațiul cuprins de un
ebit plus și putem observa că cele două generatoare stabilizatoare acționează trivial pe acest vector luând în considerare
cele două expresii ale unui ebit afișate pe ecran, împreună cu interpretarea generatoarelor stabilizatoare ca verificări de paritate în bazele 01
și plus minus codul Steane pe 7 qubiți este un alt exemplu de cod CSS deoarece pentru această
alegere de generatoare avem doar generatoare stabilizatoare Z și X și știm deja că acesta este un cod stabilizator valid
și codul Shor pe 9 qubiți este un alt exemplu de data aceasta avem șase generatoare stabilizatoare Z
și doar două generatoare stabilizatoare X și asta e în regulă, nu trebuie să existe un echilibru sau o
simetrie între cele două tipuri este totuși esențial să avem un cod stabilizator valid și asta înseamnă că
fiecare generator stabilizator Z trebuie să comute cu fiecare generator stabilizator X deci nu poți
alege pur și simplu cele două tipuri de generatoare independent și voi spune mai mult despre asta mai târziu în lecție în continuare vom discuta despre detectarea
și corecția erorilor pentru codurile CSS și ceea ce vom descoperi este că proprietatea observată pentru codul Shor pe 9 qubiți
că putem detecta și corecta erorile X și Z independent se aplică în general pentru codurile CSS
pentru a explica mai detaliat, să considerăm un cod CSS cum ar fi codul Steane pe 7 qubiți, dar ar putea fi un cod CSS diferit dacă
WEBVTT
preferi ideea de bază este că generatoarele stabilizatoare Z detectează erorile X
dar sunt complet oarbe față de erorile Z deoarece generatoarele stabilizatoare Z comută întotdeauna cu Z
erori în plus, generatoarele stabilizatoare Z comută și cu orice porți Z am putea alege să le aplicăm ca
corecții pentru erorile Z în mod similar, generatoarele stabilizatoare X detectează erorile Z, dar sunt complet
oarbe față de erorile X și corecții, deci putem în esență să ne gândim la generatoarele stabilizatoare Z ca reprezentând un
cod liniar clasic care protejează împotriva inversărilor de biți sau cu alte cuvinte erorilor X, în timp ce generatoarele stabilizatoare X
reprezintă un cod liniar clasic în baza plus minus care protejează complet independent împotriva inversărilor
între stările plus și minus sau cu alte cuvinte erorile de inversare de fază sau erorile Z deci acum este destul de clar ce se întâmplă
cu codul Steane: este pur și simplu un cod Hamming [7,4,3] pentru erorile de inversare de bit și un cod Hamming [7,4,3] pentru erorile de inversare de
fază din nou faptul că generatoarele stabilizatoare Z și X comută este necesar:
nu ar fi un cod stabilizator valid dacă nu ar comuta și s-ar putea spune că este o fericită coincidență că codul Hamming [7,4,3]
funcționează astfel, dar există multe alte alegeri care pot fi făcute pentru perechi de coduri liniare clasice care ne vor da un cod stabilizator valid
atunci când sunt combinate în acest mod acum, revenind la codurile CSS în general, să presupunem că generatoarele stabilizatoare Z
permit corectarea a până la, să zicem, j erori X și generatoarele stabilizatoare X permit corectarea a
până la k erori Z deci în cazul codului Steane, j și k sunt amândouă unu, deoarece
codul Hamming [7,4,3] poate corecta o inversare de bit, dar în general aceste numere j și k pot fi diferite
rezultă atunci prin discretizarea erorilor că codul CSS poate corecta orice eroare pe un număr de qubiți până la
minimul dintre j și k asta deoarece când măsurăm sindromul, o eroare arbitrară pe un număr de
qubiți se prăbușește probabilistic în vreo combinație de erori X, erori Z sau ambele și apoi
erorile X și Z pot fi detectate și corectate independent deci atâta timp cât avem două
coduri liniare clasice care se înțeleg în sensul că ne dau generatoare stabilizatoare x și z care comută,
codul CSS pe care îl obținem combinându-le practic moștenește proprietățile de corecție a erorilor ale celor două coduri în sensul pe care tocmai l-am
descris observă că există totuși un preț de plătit, și anume că nu putem codifica tot atâția qubiți câți biți puteam
cu cele două coduri clasice, deoarece numărul total de generatoare stabilizatoare pentru codul CSS este suma
numărului de verificări de paritate pentru cele două coduri clasice și fiecare generator stabilizator înjumătățește dimensiunea spațiului de
cod de exemplu codul Hamming [7,4,3] permite codificarea a patru biți clasici deoarece avem doar
trei verificări de paritate pentru acest cod, în timp ce codul Steane pe 7 qubiți codifică doar un qubit deoarece are șase
generatoare stabilizatoare ultimul lucru pe care îl voi explica despre codurile CSS în general în această lecție privește spațiile de cod ale codurilor CSS
și cum arată acestea și asta ne va oferi de asemenea ocazia să examinăm mai detaliat relația care trebuie să existe între
două coduri liniare clasice pentru ca ele să fie compatibile în sensul că le putem combina pentru a forma un cod CSS
să considerăm un cod CSS arbitrar pe n qubiți și fie Z1 prin Zs șirurile de verificare a parității pe n biți
care corespund generatoarelor stabilizatoare Z aceasta înseamnă că codul liniar clasic
descris de generatoarele stabilizatoare Z, pe care îl vom numi CZ doar pentru a ne aminti că acesta
este codul corespunzător generatoarelor stabilizatoare Z, ia forma afișată pe ecran cu alte cuvinte codul conține fiecare
șir u al cărui produs scalar binar cu fiecare dintre șirurile de verificare a parității este zero, ei bine, dacă am vrea am putea considera de asemenea
un cod diferit derivat din aceleași șiruri, pe care îl vom numi DZ și ideea aici este că ne gândim la
aceste șiruri Z1 prin Zs nu ca șiruri de verificare a parității, ci ca generatoare
în acest moment nu este clar de ce am vrea să ne gândim la acest cod, dar putem și se va dovedi relevant pentru această
discuție acest cod se numește codul Dual al lui CZ și este notat în mod obișnuit CZ perp, adică CZ cu simbolul perpendicular
ca superscript, dar îl vom numi DZ și va fi ușor de reținut deoarece D vine de la
dual putem face ceva similar și cu generatoarele stabilizatoare X deci de data aceasta CX este codul liniar clasic
ale cărui șiruri de verificare a parității corespund generatoarelor stabilizatoare X și DX este codul Dual al acestui cod ca paranteză
putem descrie acum condițiile care trebuie să fie îndeplinite pentru ca CZ și CX să fie compatibile în sensul că le putem
combina împreună ca un cod CSS în termenii acestor coduri înseși, mai exact trebuie ca
DZ să fie conținut în CX sau echivalent, DX să fie conținut în CZ și acum este
posibil să se descrie spațiul de cod al codului CSS derivat din aceste două coduri și o modalitate de a-l descrie este că
este spațiul cuprins de toți vectorii care iau forma afișată pe ecran cu alte cuvinte arată ca superpozitii uniforme peste șirurile din codul Dual DX
al codului corespunzător generatoarelor stabilizatoare X, deplasate
sau aplicând XOR cu șiruri din codul CZ corespunzând generatoarelor stabilizatoare Z și vom vedea cum arată asta
în cazul specific al codului Steane imediat aceasta are sens deoarece stările din spațiul de cod trebuie să fie
vectori proprii cu valoarea proprie plus unu ai tuturor generatoarelor stabilizatoare și în particular înmulțirea cu oricare dintre
generatoarele stabilizatoare X este echivalentă cu aplicarea XOR cu șirul X corespunzător, de aceea aceste superpozitii uniforme
peste DX deplasate cu șiruri diferite apar astfel, diferitele alegeri pentru deplasare
reprezentate prin șirul y în această expresie ne pot da același vector apropo, deci aceste stări nu sunt toate distincte, dar colectiv ele cuprind
întreg spațiul de cod există o simetrie aici între generatoarele stabilizatoare x și z și
codurile la care acestea corespund și deci putem folosi acea simetrie pentru a descrie vectorii din spațiul de cod într-un mod analog schimbând x-urile și z-urile, dar
trebuie de asemenea să schimbăm bazele standard cu bazele plus minus, de aceea operațiile Hadamard apar în această
expresie acum pentru exemplul promis care este codul Steane ajungem la aceste două stări codificate posibile
pentru stările bazei standard zero și unu în particular putem codifica starea zero ca o superpozitie uniformă
peste cele opt șiruri din codul Dual al codului Hamming [7,4,3] care se dovedește a fi jumătate din șirurile din codul Hamming [7,4,3] și putem
codifica starea unu într-un mod similar, cu excepția că toate șirurile sunt XOR-ate cu șirul de toți unu în acest caz
WEBVTT
deoarece acel șir se întâmplă să fie în codul Hamming [7,4,3], dar nu în dualul său un ultim comentariu: deseori
nu ne pasă prea mult cum arată vectorii din spațiile noastre de cod, deoarece în general nu avem nevoie să știm asta pentru a folosi
codurile deci dacă această explicație nu a fost clară, nu este cu adevărat ceva să-ți faci griji prea mult, dar cu siguranță este
natural să întrebi cum arată vectorii din spațiile de cod ale codurilor CSS și această descriere oferă un răspuns la acea
întrebare în continuare vom discuta despre un cod CSS specific cunoscut sub numele de codul Toric, care este un exemplu din ceea ce se numește un
cod cuantic topologic corector de erori acest cod a fost descoperit de Alexei Kitaev în
1997 de fapt codul Toric nu este un singur cod, ci o familie de coduri, câte unul pentru fiecare număr întreg pozitiv cel puțin
doi aceste coduri posedă câteva proprietăți cheie prima proprietate cheie este
că toți generatoarele stabilizatoare au greutate mică ca operații Pauli în particular vor avea toate
greutatea patru și asta e bine deoarece înseamnă că fiecare măsurătoare de generator stabilizator nu trebuie să
implice prea mulți qubiți uneori oamenii vorbesc despre coduri cuantice LDPC sau coduri cuantice de verificare a parității cu densitate
mică și asta este ceea ce înseamnă acest termen, unde în acest caz mic înseamnă patru deci codul Toric este un exemplu de
cod cuantic LDPC codul Toric are de asemenea ceea ce se numește localitate geometrică, adică
generatoarele stabilizatoare nu numai că au greutate mică, dar este și posibil să aranjăm spatial qubiții astfel încât
fiecare măsurătoare de generator stabilizator să implice numai qubiți care sunt apropiați, ceea ce face aceste măsurători mai ușor de implementat în
principiu și în final aceste coduri au distanță mare deci pot tolera o rată de erori relativ ridicată
iată cum funcționează aceste coduri mai întâi fie L un număr întreg pozitiv
cel puțin doi și considerăm o rețea L pe L cu așa-numite limite periodice
de exemplu iată o rețea L pe L pentru L egal cu 8 și observă că liniile
din dreapta și de jos sunt linii punctate și ideea este că vrem să ne gândim la linia punctată din dreapta ca fiind aceeași linie ca
linia din stânga și similar linia punctată de jos este aceeași linie ca cea de
sus deci dacă am vrea să realizăm fizic acest tip de configurație ar trebui trei
dimensiuni în particular am putea forma un cilindru potrivind mai întâi laturile stângă și dreaptă și apoi îndoind
cilindrul astfel încât cercurile de la capete, care erau înainte marginile de sus și de jos ale rețelei, să se întâlnească, sau
am putea potrivi mai întâi sus și jos și apoi laturile, funcționează în ambele moduri și nu contează în care mod o faci pentru scopul acestei
discuții ceea ce obținem este un tor sau cu alte cuvinte un gogoașă, deși a te gândi la el ca la camera unui anvelop este
poate o imagine mai bună de avut în minte deoarece nu este moale, rețeaua a devenit practic doar suprafața unui
tor și de aici vine numele de cod Toric modul în care te poți mișca pe
un tor ca acesta, presupunând că poți te mișca între puncte adiacente pe rețea, va fi probabil familiar celor care au jucat jocuri video din școala veche
unde dacă te deplasezi de pe marginea de sus a ecranului ieși pe jos și la fel pentru marginile din stânga și dreapta ale
ecranului și în cea mai mare parte acesta este modul în care voi descrie această rețea în opoziție cu a vorbi specific despre un
tor într-un spațiu tridimensional în continuare ne imaginăm că qubiții sunt
plasați pe muchiile rețelei, după cum este ilustrat pe ecran unde qubiții sunt indicați prin cercuri albastre pline
observă apropo că qubiții plasați pe liniile punctate nu sunt solizi și asta este deoarece i-am reprezentat deja pe acei qubiți
fie prin cei de sus, fie prin cei din stânga, ținând minte că liniile de sus și de stânga sunt exact aceleași linii ca cele
indicate prin liniile punctate de jos și dreapta și deci dacă numărăm toți acești qubiți obținem 2 * L² qubiți și o
modalitate de a vedea asta este să observăm că obținem L² qubiți pe muchii orizontale și L² qubiți pe muchii verticale
deci aceasta este dispunerea qubiților noștri și pentru a descrie codul Toric însuși trebuie doar să descriem generatoarele
stabilizatoare și există două tipuri în primul rând avem generatoare stabilizatoare Z
și acestea corespund faianțelor sau plăcilor din figură și în al doilea rând avem generatoare stabilizatoare X
și acestea corespund vârfurilor din figură deci de exemplu iată un
generator stabilizator, adică tensorizăm o operație Pauli Z pentru fiecare dintre qubiții care ating această faianță împreună cu matrici identitate
pe toți ceilalți qubiți și asta ne dă o operație Pauli de greutate patru și iată un exemplu de generator stabilizator X
unde avem matrici Pauli X acționând pe cei patru qubiți adiacenți acestui vârf împreună cu
matrici identitate pe toți ceilalți qubiți deci din nou este o operație Pauli de greutate patru este important că pentru ambele
aceste tipuri de generatoare stabilizatoare includeri pe cele care înconjoară la limitele periodice și iată un exemplu de generator stabilizator X care
face asta acum pentru a obține un cod stabilizator valid avem nevoie ca generatoarele
stabilizatoare să comute generatoarele stabilizatoare Z comută toate între ele deoarece Z comută cu el însuși și identitatea
comută cu orice și la fel pentru generatoarele stabilizatoare X este de asemenea clar că un generator stabilizator Z și un generator stabilizator X
comută când acționează non-trivial pe mulțimi disjuncte de qubiți, ca pentru cei doi generatoare care sunt afișați
posibilitatea rămasă este că un generator stabilizator Z și un generator stabilizator X se suprapun și
ori de câte ori se întâmplă asta se suprapun întotdeauna pe doi qubiți și deci generatoarele stabilizatoare comută deoarece ZZ
și XX comută acum acesta nu este un set minimal de generatoare stabilizatoare în particular dacă înmulțim
toți generatoarele stabilizatoare Z împreună obținem identitatea deoarece fiecare qubit este înmulțit cu Z de două ori
câte o dată pentru fiecare faianță care atinge qubit-ul asta înseamnă că înmulțind toți generatoarele stabilizatoare Z împreună
cu excepția unuia dintre ei ne dă pe acela din urmă deci nu sunt independente, dar dacă îndepărtăm oricare dintre ele vom obține
un set independent și același lucru este adevărat pentru generatoarele stabilizatoare X deci putem îndepărta câte unul din fiecare
și nu contează care îndepărtăm și asta lasă L² minus unu generatoare stabilizatoare din fiecare tip pentru a fi
clar despre asta, și acesta este ceva la care am făcut aluzie în lecția anterioară, chiar ne pasă despre toți acești generatoare stabilizatoare și în sens strict
operațional nu vom alege de fapt câte unul din fiecare tip de ignorat, dar pentru a analiza codul putem
imagina că un generator stabilizator din fiecare tip a fost îndepărtat astfel încât să obținem un set minimal de generare ținând minte
WEBVTT
că am putea întotdeauna deduce rezultatele acestor generatoare îndepărtate, gândindu-ne la ele ca observabile, din rezultatele tuturor celorlalte generatoare
stabilizatoare de același tip deci numărul de qubiți pe care îi codifică acest cod este egal cu numărul total de
qubiți care este 2 * L² minus numărul total de generatoare stabilizatoare dintr-un set minimal de generare care este 2 * L² -
1 și asta înseamnă că putem codifica 2 qubiți nu am argumentat apropo că spațiul de cod este non-trivial, dar într-adevăr
este non-trivial și îți las ție să te convingi că nu există nicio modalitate de a înmulți generatoarele stabilizatoare astfel încât să obținem
negativ -1 ori identitatea deci acesta este codul Toric însuși și în acest moment s-ar putea să nu fie
deloc clar de ce acest cod ar trebui să fie bun pentru corecția cuantică a erorilor rămâne pentru noi să îl analizăm și ceea ce vom descoperi este că este în
fapt un cod cuantic corector de erori destul de uimitor pentru a înțelege cum funcționează codul Toric ca cod cuantic corector de
erori vom începe prin a considera diferite erori și sindroamele pe care le generează primul lucru de observat este că
codul Toric este un cod CSS deoarece toți generatoarele noastre stabilizatoare sunt fie generatoare stabilizatoare Z fie X
și asta înseamnă că erorile X și Z pot fi detectate și eventual corectate
separat și de fapt există o simplă simetrie între generatoarele stabilizatoare Z și X care ne permite să analizăm erorile X
și Z în esență în același mod deci mă voi concentra pe erorile X care sunt detectate posibil de generatoarele stabilizatoare Z
și poți transpune totul la erorile Z care sunt detectate posibil de generatoarele stabilizatoare X folosind exact aceleași
idei iată o figură care ilustrează cei 2L² qubiți de pe muchiile unei rețele L
pe L cu limite periodice și ne putem imagina că aceasta este dispusă pe suprafața unui
tor în prezent toți qubiții sunt albaștri indicând că aceștia sunt qubiți care nu au fost afectați de
erori deci ar trebui să-ți imaginezi că în acest moment starea acestor qubiți este în spațiul de cod pentru acest
cod după cum am menționat atenția noastră se va concentra pe erorile X și imediat vom folosi cercuri magenta pentru a indica qubiții care
au fost afectați de erori X erorile X sunt detectate de generatoarele stabilizatoare Z care corespund
faianțelor din figură deci ce putem face este să lăsăm faianțele albe să indice rezultate de măsurătoare plus unu sau cu alte cuvinte
intrări în sindrom corespunzătoare acelui generator, în timp ce faianțele gri vor indica rezultate de măsurătoare minus unu
poți te gândi la un rezultat plus unu sau cu alte cuvinte o faianță albă ca indicând că generatorul stabilizator corespunzător este
fericit, totul pare să fie în regulă pentru acest generator, în timp ce un rezultat minus unu sau o faianță gri
indică faptul că generatorul stabilizator corespunzător este nefericit deoarece evident o eroare trebuie să fi apărut pentru a provoca acest
rezultat deci în prezent toți generatoarele noastre stabilizatoare sunt fericite deoarece nu s-au produs erori acum dacă ne gândim
la un generator stabilizator Z tot ce face este să măsoare paritatea celor 4 qubiți care ating faianța cu
privire la baza standard deci un rezultat plus unu nu indică faptul că nu s-au produs erori X pe acești patru
qubiți ci mai degrabă indică că s-a produs un număr par de erori X, în timp ce un rezultat minus unu indică
că s-a produs un număr impar de erori X deci acum să introducem o eroare X și să vedem ce
se întâmplă cei doi generatoare stabilizatoare Z corespunzători faianțelor care ating acest qubit sunt acum nefericiți deoarece această
eroare X anticomută cu ambii acești generatoare sau echivalent în termenii bazei standard ne aflăm acum într-o
stare în care ambele aceste seturi de patru qubiți corespunzători celor două faianțe au paritate impară deci acesta este efectul unui singur
eroare X deci dacă ar fi să măsurăm acest sindrom și am ști sau am presupune că s-a produs doar o singură eroare X am putea
deduce cu ușurință care qubit a fost inversat și l-am putea pur și simplu inversa înapoi cu o poartă X acum să vedem ce se întâmplă
când introducem erori X suplimentare și în particular să vedem ce se întâmplă când o a doua eroare X apare pe un alt
qubit care atinge una dintre faianțele gri să zicem faianța gri de sus ca
aceasta acea faianță este acum fericită deoarece s-au produs două erori X pe qubiții care ating această faianță și doi este par deci
aceste două erori X comută împreună cu generatorul stabilizator pentru această faianță un alt mod de a spune asta este că
această a doua eroare X a deplasat toate stările bazei standard ale acestor patru qubiți de la paritate impară înapoi la paritate pară
faianța din stânga acestei noi erori X pe de altă parte este acum nefericită
putem continua acest proces de adăugare de noi erori X și atâta timp cât formăm un lanț de erori X adiacente unde adiacent înseamnă că qubiții ating
aceeași faianță vom deplasa efectiv acest rezultat de măsurătoare minus 1 și ceea ce găsim este că avem întotdeauna
rezultate de măsurătoare de sindrom minus unu la capetele lanțurilor de erori adiacente deci putem detecta întotdeauna lanțuri de
erori X adiacente atâta timp cât au capete ar putea fi apropo mai multe lanțuri, dar vom reveni
la această posibilitate mai târziu este totuși posibil să avem un lanț de erori X adiacente care
nu are capete ceea ce înseamnă că lanțul nostru de erori ar putea forma o buclă închisă deci să adăugăm mai multe erori astfel
încât să formeze o buclă închisă ca aceasta de exemplu acum avem un număr par de erori X
pe fiecare faianță deci fiecare generator stabilizator este acum fericit și ceea ce am găsit este că buclele
închise de erori X adiacente nu sunt detectate de acest cod deoarece obținem sindromul de toți plus 1 în astfel de
cazuri deci asta poate părea oarecum descurajator de fapt avem nevoie de numai patru erori X adiacente pentru a forma o buclă închisă
și sperăm la ceva mai bun decât un cod de distanță 4 totuși unele bucle închise de
erori X adiacente sunt ele însele în stabilizator amintește-ți că avem un generator stabilizator X pentru fiecare vârf din
rețea și dacă înmulțim generatoarele stabilizatoare X adiacente putem forma bucle închise de operații X
cum ar fi cele pe care le avem chiar aici pentru bucla închisă pe care am construit-o cu câteva momente în urmă deci unele bucle închise de erori X
ca cea afișată nu sunt de fapt erori deoarece sunt în stabilizator deci nu fac nimic deloc spațiului de cod există totuși
unele bucle închise de erori X care nu sunt în stabilizator și prin urmare reprezintă erori non-triviale care trec
nedetectate de cod și există o modalitate destul de simplă de a caracteriza diferitele tipuri de
bucle buclele care traversează fiecare linie din rețea, adică fiecare linie verticală de sus în jos și fiecare linie orizontală
de la stânga la dreapta de un număr par de ori sunt întotdeauna produse de generatoare stabilizatoare X, ceea ce include exemplul
afișat pe ecran precum și bucle care pot fi mult mai complicate, inclusiv posibilitatea că traversează limitele periodice, dar
WEBVTT
cu toate acestea înmulțind aceste bucle închise de erori X cu generatoarele stabilizatoare X ele pot fi efectiv reduse până la
nimic și cu siguranță este adevărat apropo că putem obține bucle ca aceasta numai înmulțind generatoarele stabilizatoare X deoarece fiecare generator stabilizator X
pune un număr par de operații X pe fiecare linie orizontală și pe fiecare linie verticală
celălalt tip de buclă închisă pe care o putem avea este una care traversează cel puțin o linie de un număr impar de ori, cum ar fi
cea afișată care traversează fiecare linie orizontală exact o singură dată și iată un alt exemplu care traversează
fiecare linie verticală exact o singură dată deci acestea sunt exemple de erori non-triviale care trec nedetectate de cod, dar
cheia este că singura modalitate de a forma o buclă ca aceasta este să mergi în jurul torului fie în jurul găurii din
mijlocul torului, fie prin gaură sau ar putea fi ambele aceasta este o proprietate topologică
referitoare la tor este în esență despre găuri și de aceea acesta se numește cod cuantic topologic corector de
erori în termeni ai acestei vizualizări a unei rețele bidimensionale cu limite periodice un lanț din această categorie trebuie
să facă bucla în jurul uneia sau ambelor limite periodice într-un mod care face imposibilă contracția acelei bucle la un
punct prin înmulțirea cu generatoare stabilizatoare X un astfel de lanț ar putea fi mai
complicat decât cel ilustrat, dar acesta este cel mai scurt pe care o astfel de buclă ar putea fi deoarece trebuie cumva să facă bucla în jurul
uneia sau ambelor limite periodice și ceea ce implică asta este că greutatea minimă a unei erori non-triviale
nedetectabile este L orice buclă închisă cu mai puține erori decât atât trebuie să cadă în prima categorie și este deci
în stabilizator și lanțurile de erori care nu formează bucle închise sunt detectate de cod și acesta este motivul pentru care funcționează acest cod
și cu ce rămânem este un cod stabilizator [[2L², 2, L]] folosim 2L²
qubiți pentru a codifica 2 qubiți și codul are distanța L în continuare voi spune doar câte ceva despre
corectarea erorilor cu codul Toric, deși nu voi intra prea mult în detalii dacă măsurăm sindromul și
vedem altceva decât sindromul de toți plus 1, unde vorbesc aici doar despre generatoarele stabilizatoare Z,
atunci rezultatele minus unu ne indică capetele unuia sau mai multor lanțuri de erori X adiacente și putem încerca să corectăm
aceste erori asociind rezultatele minus unu în perechi și formând un lanț de corecții X între ele și
când facem asta are sens să alegem căile cele mai scurte pentru corecțiile noastre de exemplu dacă măsurăm un
sindrom cum ar fi cel afișat, atunci am putea alege această cale între faianțele nefericite și aplica porți X
ca corecții de-a lungul acestei căi desigur lanțul actual de erori care provoacă sindromul ar fi putut
fi diferit cum ar fi cel afișat, dar asta e în regulă atâta timp cât erorile și corecțiile împreună
cad în stabilizator s-ar putea de asemenea ca corecțiile noastre să completeze o buclă în jurul
torului ceea ce este rău deoarece astfel am provocat o eroare logică deci această strategie de corectare
de-a lungul căilor cele mai scurte corectează erorile de greutate mică, dar s-ar putea să nu funcționeze pentru erorile de greutate mai mare dar desigur nu putem
aștepta mai mult de la niciun cod cuantic corector de erori mai probabil poate în funcție de modelul de zgomot este că
observăm o grămadă de minus unu în sindrom și în acest caz putem folosi algoritmi clasici eficienți pentru a ne ajuta
să le asociem în perechi și să găsim o eroare de greutate minimă reprezentând sindromul după cum am menționat în lecția anterioară
aceasta s-ar putea să nu corecteze întotdeauna explicația cea mai probabilă a sindromului, dar funcționează destul de bine în general
și reușește întotdeauna să corecteze erorile cu greutate strict mai mică decât jumătate din distanța L și ar trebui de asemenea să
menționez că există și alte strategii mai potrivite pentru diferite modele de erori au trecut peste 25 de ani de când
codul Toric a fost descoperit și în acel timp s-a făcut destul de multă muncă pe coduri cuantice corectoare de erori inclusiv
alte coduri cuantice topologice corectoare de erori inspirate de codul Toric precum și coduri bazate pe idei
diferite cu siguranță nu pot să-ți dau o listă cuprinzătoare a tuturor construcțiilor de coduri diferite care sunt cunoscute, dar voi zgâria puțin la suprafață
și voi menționa pe scurt câteva exemple bine cunoscute mai întâi după cum se dovedește nu este
cu adevărat esențial ca codul Toric să aibă limite periodice, adică este posibil să tai doar o porțiune din codul Toric și
să o aplatizezi pe o suprafață bidimensională mai degrabă decât pe un tor și ceea ce obținem făcând asta se numește cod de
suprafață de exemplu dacă tăiem marginile unei rețele în modelul afișat cu așa-numitele margini aspre la
sus și jos și margini netede la lateral și corespunzător includem cazuri de margine pentru generatoarele stabilizatoare
atunci ajungem cu un cod care poate codifica un singur qubit de data aceasta, dar codul moștenește totuși cele mai
importante caracteristici ale codului Toric în particular erorile non-triviale nedetectabile pentru acest cod trebuie
să corespundă lanțurilor de erori care se întind fie de la marginea stângă la marginea dreaptă, fie de sus la jos
în funcție de dacă sunt lanțuri de erori X sau Z respectiv este de asemenea posibil să tăiem
marginile în diagonală pentru a obține ceea ce sunt numite uneori coduri de suprafață rotite și asta poate fi util pentru a face
codurile mai economice în termeni de câți qubiți sunt folosiți de exemplu dacă luăm acest cod de
suprafață și aruncăm unii dintre qubiți lăsând un pătrat orientat diagonal obținem un alt cod de
suprafață atâta timp cât specificăm generatoarele stabilizatoare de pe margine în modul corect diagramele ca aceasta sunt
utile pentru a face clar cum sunt definite generatoarele stabilizatoare unde faianțele negre inclusiv cele rotunjite de pe margini indică generatoarele stabilizatoare X
și cele albe indică generatoarele stabilizatoare Z cele de pe margine apropo sunt doar generatoare stabilizatoare XX de 2 qubiți
sau ZZ de data aceasta și vei vedea în mod obișnuit aceste diagrame rotate cu
45° o altă clasă interesantă de coduri care se încadrează și în categoria generală a codurilor topologice sunt codurile de
culoare nu voi explica exact cum funcționează, dar o modalitate de a te gândi la ele este că sunt generalizări geometrice
ale codului Steane pe 7 qubiți deci să considerăm codul Steane pe șapte qubiți și să presupunem că numerotăm
qubiții folosind convenția de ordonare KCET după cum este afișat pe ecran putem apoi asocia acești șapte
qubiți cu vârfurile grafului afișat și ceea ce găsim este că generatoarele stabilizatoare se potrivesc
cu faianțele sau fețele formate de muchiile grafului și pentru fiecare faianță avem întotdeauna un generator stabilizator Z
și un generator stabilizator X care acționează non-trivial exact pe acei qubiți găsiți la vârfurile acelei
WEBVTT
faianțe aceasta este frumos deoarece la fel ca pentru codul Toric avem localitate geometrică pentru acest cod deci nu este nevoie
să deplasăm qubiți pe distanțe lungi pentru a măsura generatoarele stabilizatoare și faptul că generatoarele stabilizatoare Z și X acționează întotdeauna non-trivial pe
exact aceleași seturi de qubiți este de asemenea bun din motive legate de computația cuantică tolerantă la defecte, despre care voi
spune mai mult în lecția următoare codurile de culoare sunt coduri cuantice corectoare de erori care generalizează acest
pattern de bază unde facem în esență același lucru cu excepția grafurilor diferite de exemplu iată un graf cu
19 vârfuri care funcționează acesta ne dă un cod care codifică 1 qubit în 19 și se întâmplă să aibă
distanța cinci acestea se numesc coduri de culoare apropo deoarece una dintre condițiile necesare pe graf este că fețele pot fi colorate cu trei culori, adică
putem colora fețele cu trei culori și nu avem niciodată două fețe de aceeași culoare care să partajeze o muchie
culorile nu contează de fapt pentru codul însuși, pur și simplu avem generatoare stabilizatoare x și z pentru fiecare față indiferent de culoarea ei, dar culorile
se dovedesc a fi importante pentru analiza modului în care funcționează deci acestea sunt două familii de coduri foarte bine cunoscute
dar există multe alte construcții cunoscute inclusiv unele bazate pe idei similare acestor familii de coduri precum și
unele complet diferite un exemplu specific de cod cuantic corector de erori care a fost descoperit recent
de câțiva dintre colegii mei de la IBM este cunoscut sub numele de codul gross care este numit astfel deoarece un gross este o duzină
de duzini sau 144 în particular acest cod codifică 12 qubiți în 144 de qubiți și are
distanța 12 nu voi explica cum funcționează acest cod în detaliu, este similar cu codul Toric cu excepția că fiecare
generator stabilizator implică acum doi qubiți suplimentari care sunt puțin mai departe nu are o planare embedding
ca un cod de suprafață, dar are o așa-numită biplanar embedding adică sunt necesare două straturi de qubiți în loc de
unul se încadrează într-o familie de coduri numite coduri bivariate bicycle și ceea ce este deosebit de remarcabil despre ele este
că sunt mult mai eficiente decât codul Toric sau un cod de suprafață în sensul că mult mai mulți qubiți pot fi codificați în timp ce simultan
tolerează aproximativ aceeași rată de erori pentru codul gross sunt necesari suplimentar 144 de qubiți pentru sindromul de
măsurare deci numărul total de qubiți necesar este 288, ceea ce îl face un candidat foarte promițător pentru tehnologia de astăzi
și aceasta concluzionează această lecție care a fost despre construcții de coduri cuantice corectoare de erori inclusiv coduri CSS, codul Toric și o
privire la alte construcții de coduri cuantice inclusiv coduri de suprafață și coduri de culoare sper că vei fi alături de mine pentru
lecția finală a seriei despre computația cuantică tolerantă la defecte, care abordează provocarea de a efectua
calcule pe stări cuantice codificate folosind operații și componente de calcul care sunt ele însele predispuse la
erori la revedere până atunci